the first time I did I always go I just
experienced pure love that I'd never
accessed before I think there were great
potential I don't think they are the
answer I don't think they are the future
I think the future has to be far more
with the transformation of people and of
social structures and and the culture
itself but the second to do is they
offer they show you a great potential
what shows up things you're not aware of
it's almost like there's a membrane
between our conscious minds and all the
stuff we carry in our subconscious and
the psychedelics remove the membrane
it's almost like you can have a waking
dream and experience all the rage all
the hatred maybe all the terror all the
fear but all the beauty all the love all
the Oneness all the unity all the joy
all the presence can put in touch with
that Unity that we're all a part of but
we're hardly aware of it in this culture
which is all about competition and
aggression greed and acquisition
propaganda is into forgetting that unity
and that Oneness and that
intercorrection and second that's going
to open that up beautifully